welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the sexploits of America's ass
is a major takeaway from the She-Hulk
episode 1 post-credit scene but we've
been so preoccupied with whether Captain
America [ __ ] that we didn't have to
consider whether he's still [ __ ] yes
was the deeper reveal of this moment
actually that Steve Rogers in the MCU is
still alive and if he is still alive
where is he and is he using protection
because I assume the super soldier serum
even at that age keeps him doing it all
day let's re-examine the moment from the
post-credits scene
Steve Rogers did so much for his country
and he never got to experience sex did
you see that ass like that ass did not
deserved a Divergent it's like so sad
Steve Rogers is not a virgin he lost his
virginity to a girl in 1943 on the USO
tour yes I knew it you're not drunk
Captain America
functions line because it keeps it the
long-standing MCU tradition
s deep but no further than that
what the [ __ ] but even more curious
about this cut to Black is it deprives
us from knowing what verb tense Jen was
using there did she say Captain America
or Captain America
like notice how Jen when she is
pretending to be drunk with Bruce speaks
of Steve Rogers in the past tense saying
he died a virgin but when Bruce corrects
her he switches to present tense Steve
Rogers is not a virgin so in a way her
yes I knew it was kind of a lawyery's
semantic trap for her cousin she
deliberately used past tense so that
Bruce might trip up and correct her to
use the present tense which would in
effect prove that Steve Rogers is still
alive because Bruce does not say Steve
Rogers was not a virgin which would be
the rational response to correcting
someone saying a guy died a virgin he
says is not a virgin as in Steve
continues to live and breathe as a guy
who to reference by alma mater the
University of Florida go Gators
a guy who graduated without a brick
falling from Century Tower Chris Evans
tweeted his response to this episode
suggesting his lips were sealed and Mark
Ruffalo responded apologizing saying he
was under extreme duress so what secret
did Bruce really spoil here is it that
big of a deal that the public knows that
Captain America was not a virgin not
really I mean when Sam asked about his
wedding ring old man cap smiled and said
that he didn't want to get into it but
if a wedding ring means anything folks
it means that this guy
[Music]
I mean perhaps a bigger secret is that
Bruce accidentally also spoiled that
Steve Rogers is still alive in the MCU
if something's worth doing it's worth
doing right and for me sleeping is worth
doing that means it's worth doing right
and that's where Helix sleep comes in
Helix sleep makes premium mattresses and
betting customized to fit your needs and
shipped right to your door and look I'm
not a sleepologist or anything but I
don't need to be Helix is a sleep quiz
that matches your unique body type and
your sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you you can even take it
with a partner and find the mattress
that's a perfect compromise between both
your preferences I took the quiz I
wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool and I
got matched with the dusk Luxe Helix
mattress I've had it for quite some time
now and I love it so much I sleep better
and wake up less often than I used to
Helix delivers your mattress right to
your door for free it comes rolled up in
a shockingly tiny box and it's super
easy to set up yourself Helix has a 100
night sleep trial so you'll get more
than three months to make sure that you
love your mattress and if you don't
they'll pick it up for you you'll get a
photo refund and these mattresses also
have a 10 year warranty that's an entire
decade Helix even has financing options
and flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep it's never far away I love
my Helix I think you would too so if
you're looking for a new bed check out
Helix you can click the link below or go
to helixsleep.com new rockstars and get
up to 200 off your Helix mattress Marvel
phase 4 has been mixed about the current
status of Steve Rogers Spider-Man far
from home open with a tribute video to
Steve Rogers Tony Stark vision and black
widow the students of Midtown High
assuming that Steve was dead in Eternal
Sprite says so now that Captain Rogers
Man Iron Man are both gone who do you
think's Gonna Leave The Avengers in
Spider-Man no way home new yorker's ad
at Captain America shield of the Statue
of Liberty as if in a kind of tribute
but while we saw that memorial wall
shouting out Tony Stark and Natasha
Romanov as recently as Ms Marvel episode
1 at Adventure con we have seen no such
tombstones memorials for Steve Rogers
explicitly the Falcon the Winter Soldier
showed Steve Smithsonian exhibit when he
looked closely at that final placard the
one that reads final mission it reads
with the death of Tony Stark Steve
Rogers honored his friend by finally
retiring and laying down his shield
enjoying the world he had fought so hard
to protect with this exhibit we honor
The Life and Legacy of Steve Rogers
Captain America patriot soldier hero yes
the word is retired it says nothing
about his death furthermore the Falcons
winner soldier episode 1 featured
Joaquin Torres citing conspiracy
theories about Steve's current
whereabouts I do gotta ask you though
because like online there's just been a
lot of a lot of stuff about Steve
actually
um crazy crazy conspiracy theories some
people they think that he's in secret
based on the moon looking down over us I
can assure you those people you don't
have to take serious but you didn't like
fly them to the moon no and by the way
that episode was titled New World Order
and what is the title the next Captain
America film Captain America new world
order something tells me this crazy
crazy New World Order conspiracy theory
might be proven true because if Marvel
Studios wanted us to conclude for sure
that old Steve Rogers was dead at this
point for good we definitely would have
seen some grave like we did for Natasha
and they definitely would not have used
a vague term like retired or floated
around some loony conspiracy theories
that you know YouTubers like us are
going to question endlessly so as phase
five begins one of the first MCU titles
we can expect is a story all about
government conspiracy theories secret
Invasion this will likely include what
exactly Nick Fury was doing on that
squirrel space station in that
Spider-Man far from home post credit
scene and the possibility that old Steve
Rogers could secretly be Consulting Fury
and some contacts at soared aboard a
space station called the peak after the
secret Invasion trailer dropped
exclusively for attendees of Comic-Con
rumors are now swirling that Olivia
Coleman's character might be a version
of Union Jack named paulsworth perhaps
the grand and daughter of James
Montgomery Falls birth of the Howling
Commandos in the 2011 Captain America
film this Legacy connection could be how
old Steve Rogers ties into the secret
Invasion storyline at the very least we
could get an answer to where exactly he
is or that he is somewhere other
surviving Avengers at the end of end
game the only ones who were in the
vicinity of old Steve Rogers in that
moment were Sam Wilson Bucky Barnes and
Bruce Banner remember Bruce was last
seen slapping the quantum controls he
assumed that they had malfunctioned
since Steve had not immediately returned
up from the quantum tunnel Bruce would
have had to have been part of whatever
conspiracy to get old Steve Rogers into
hiding we can assume Bucky was part of
that as well he did end up with Steve's
things to look up notebook from Captain
America the Winter Soldier remember
Bucky used this to list names of people
to make amends with so when we think
about the places in the MCU old Steve
Rogers could be hiding wakanda maybe
Tony's Farm maybe somewhere in Brooklyn
or Jersey keep it a low profile of all
these an orbital base in space makes the
most sense as a place where Steve could
avoid the public eye and keep his eye on
extraterrestrial threats like another
Thanos or some more recent threats like
the celestial being in orbit or threats
posed by the invading Creed so will the
truth of Steve's fate get revealed in
She-Hulk I'm not so sure but do not be
surprised if Bruce suddenly has to take
off into space to apologize for the
boulder he threw into the stratosphere
that could have nearly taken out Steve's
space station and interrupted some
passionate space and with a squirrel who
does a great Peggy Carter impression let
me know your thoughts on this question
and follow me on Tick Tock Instagram and
Twitter at E A Vos subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis everything
you love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you